[Music]
all right
people are upset people are asking how
do you go
from nwa to mega ice cube
ice cube wait what happened what
happened what happened what happened
fans are blasting ice cube as a sellout
and a hypocrite
after the trump campaign revealed he has
been working alongside
the president on a bid to create 3
million jobs for african americans
what's going on confusion
that sounds like good news yeah why is
it mutually exclusive so
the way i'm doing just from the
headlines right i don't know much about
it nwa
it was for the people right like [ __ ]
police
yeah like he's like like we need better
situation for ourselves
the three million jobs also seems like
better situation for ourselves
right so it seems like they're not
mutually exclusive they're in the same
i don't know mode of thought wait so
is it like um you're backstabbing us yes
a lot a lot of people are saying
ice cubes turning their back on the the
black community
and uh going basically working with the
enemy
to to to help the black community it
seems like like
and when i say that out loud it kind of
sounds kind of ironic yeah so that's the
part that i'm a little bit confused so
can you give us a little bit more
insight on why people are upset
all right so ice cube yeah so ice cube
didn't actually come out with this
information and in fact he has not
endorsed
either uh presidential nominee uh
nominee that's what happens to us
yeah true people think all this [ __ ]
like i'm a trump supporter and all this
[ __ ] and i'm all like man kanye 2020
[ __ ] y'all
birthday party i want colonel sanders to
be president
i like colonel sanders yeah all right so
the news all right so the news made its
way to twitter
via someone else other than ice cube
it's this person called katrina pearson
why is a hurricane from [ __ ] dude i
heard hurricanes
have last names yeah now they do
i think that she's a republican
supporter or whatever uh so she said
shout out to ice cube for his
willingness to
step up and work with donald trump
administration to help develop
the hashtag platinum plan and the
platinum plan is something that the
donald trump campaign is trying to
develop
to uh help the economy and i think
specifically targeting
the african-american community i thought
you put leaders gonna lead haters gonna
hate
thank you for leading oh my god brown
emoji like brown skin emoji she had a
search for that one she's like oh i
didn't know they had different colors
oh yeah yeah we need to see what she
really looks like like yeah like a like
a like a tornado
or like uh how do i wait oh i just oh
here we go we need to see the thermal
version yeah so she throws in a little
bit of a
political jab here leader's gonna lead
hater's gonna
she did the thank you for leading yes
and then she's a white woman
yeah and she's a white woman ice cube's
new album i see my i see my
okay i'm still confused is it because
people who think that
uh the trump administration is the enemy
are they saying that uh black people
shouldn't be republican
or is it specifically trump uh i think
it's a little bit of both
i mean for sure both yeah so i think you
know trump has said a lot of outlandish
things he's tweeted a lot of outlandish
things
especially uh things that are you know
you know
racially uh you know controversial i
would say
and um and then obviously the republican
party
uh you know at least how the media
portrays it
you know has a lot of uh white
supporters we know what the platinum
plan
has in there like are people actually
upset of the
the contents in the proposal that
icecube is participating in
i think it's 16 tracks and three of them
have to be club
and it's gonna go platinum baby yes
the platinum plan is something that
donald trump's
uh camp is working on what ice cube is
trying to do
is he has a his his contract his
proposed idea is called
contract with black america cwba yeah
and that's what he's trying to uh to to
to get developed by either party so
in his responses to all the all the
tweets and stuff
he said his efforts were bipartisan he's
reached out to both the democrats
and the republicans and he just says
well you know honestly biden's camp
they were kind of like lukewarm to the
idea and then when i presented to
trump's camp
they were a lot more enthusiastic about
it they were they were
willing to jump on top of this and and
and you know work something out that's
dope so he just said
i'm going to work with you guys and so
that's kind of like that's true the end
all of
like his his perspective on the
situation so do we know what it was that
he presented like what
no it's still like under wraps i don't i
think they're still you know obviously
developing it
um let me find something the sad thing
is like so i don't even know what ice
cube's plan is but
hearing it at least from his point of
view him saying i have something
positive i want to do for my community
and i pitched it to two people the fact
that
someone even has a plan and people
immediately go sell
out it discourages people from doing
positive things like instead of looking
at what the
actual actions are people are just
judging things based off of association
and that kind of sucks i i kind of get
it grades in school and they go nerd
what you like school i kind of
get it because like if i could put
myself in the mind of someone who thinks
that the trump administration if all of
that is the enemy
then that's like saying hey i'm against
big pharma
right but then you guys are working with
big pharma
to help the asian community create like
music schools and [ __ ] like that i can't
back that
even though you're doing something good
for our team but then
that's kind of what i equate this to
yeah because in this case
i actually side with ice cube more
because it's like yo
all i'm trying to do is stimulate our
community's economy
[ __ ] make it better who the [ __ ]
cares if this is
like even working with the cartel i'm
making lives better for us yeah because
i'm sure ice cube would love to work
with the democrats too i i would say i
mean a greater good right
bipartisan here yeah so someone said my
hip hop hero
ice cube is working with the dark side i
haven't felt this low since kobe passed
heartbreaking uh cube i'm not sure you
understand how much we value your voice
and when we see you jumping the shark it
kills us especially in 2020
ice cube responds every side [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ] you
we don't need you uh every side is the
dark side
here in america yeah they're all the
same until something changes for us
they all lie they all cheat but we can't
afford not to negotiate with whoever is
in power or our condition in this
country will never change
that's why justice is bipartisan that's
dude
and that's that's how you have to that's
how you have to deal with it right yeah
what else are you gonna do see this is
what blows my mind right
it's we have shittier and shittier as as
choices for politician
politicians right and you just kind of
try to figure out which one's probably
gonna be the least
shittiest but there's a [ __ ] ton of
people
on both sides that go oh we're the good
guys and you guys are the bad guys
it's like we're all americans man like
why do you actually think that these
politicians
care about what the [ __ ] is happening to
you
your health your [ __ ] wealth they
don't give a [ __ ] dude
all it is is let me become in positions
of power
how am i gonna make me and my friends
rich that's literally how they [ __ ]
roll
and when i say this it's like you're
[ __ ] crazy that's not how it works
whatever we're the good guys they're the
bad guys i'm like you're delusional bro
that's even ice cuban sees this and i i
know he has
access to a lot of powerful people and
he's been in this world for like so long
not in the world of politics
but in the world of like prestigious
people like celebrities like bakers
whatever right
he sees it for what it is and it's so
difficult for me because i'm like
man it sucks that people actually think
that there is some type of virtuous side
and a better hero that is not wrong and
i'm like
everyone's a [ __ ] dude for sure he
started this gangster shin this is the
[ __ ]
thing wow
a lot of people don't care if you've
been waiting on that that was a good one
that's good
yeah good moment by the way i just
wanted to touch you a little bit so
where's that
today's a good day oh my god
a lot of people calling uh ice cube a a
hypocrite because
through his music he's you know said
[ __ ] the police he's also daddy daycare
too
yeah yeah he enjoys haircuts as well
yeah yeah and then there's also a line
in one of his songs where he actually
said something about
uh never wanting to have dinner with the
president or something like that
and he's even talked about donald trump
like antagonizing donald trump in his
past music so
a lot of people are taking his music as
like a judgment of his like you know
her philosophy so you must think this
forever and if you don't
that was like 40 years ago but also like
working with somebody and supporting
them
isn't necessarily the same thing right
yeah that's true it's like he's working
to get something he has his own agenda
and and if if
by by teaming up with this other entity
helps your agenda
get going like that's i think that's how
he's seeing donald trump as a
tool and he's just using the tool yeah
because he tried to build a tool
yeah exactly he tried to go to biden
and maybe he got turned down by them so
it's like what else is he gonna do and
he's not even like going to these
specific people he's going to their
administration
right to work with other people that uh
are just
like means to an end right like it's a
means to an
end you you have to do certain things
sometimes that's why i was focused so
heavily on like what is the thing that
he's presenting what is the thing that
he's actually trying to get no one's
looking at that though right so that's
what i'm saying like if people are
actually
looking at the content and they're like
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] ice cube
like this
what's this [ __ ] 300 million jobs
this is nonsense dude
it's way too many jobs jobs no that's
what they're mad about it's too many
jobs two-minute jobs yeah it doesn't
seem like any any specifics have come
out yet about
whatever the plans are uh don cheadle
the actor he's he's kind of like he kind
of hit that point he was like in his
tweet
uh in response to this he was like what
adjustments specifically in response to
ice cube saying like the trump campaign
or making adjustments to
ice cube uh pr uh a puzzle proposal to
adjust it into the platinum plan so like
basically it's like a merger of the two
plans
and so ice cube i mean don cheadle is
like what adjustments specifically and
what's your end game so he's
he's asking a good question like what
exactly are you trying to get at because
like even for us like you know we work
with brands and stuff all the time and
like let's say we
write a movie and we pitch it to
sriracha or something and they turn it
down but then if heinz picks us up and
for people to call a sellout
that would suck they're like why don't
you work with the asian company well you
don't you don't know what goes on behind
closed doors and we're just trying to
make things happen
issue here is like they
think that one party is morally wrong
and one party is morally right
yeah so that's why i mean like if it's
two sauce companies
there's no feeling of um that's the
enemy that's hurting us and you're
working with someone true
so i think that's what what's really the
the issue here
is like you're like yo uh we're the same
crew like we're like the same tribe
why are you working with the enemy i
don't care if you're trying to get
something good
yeah i could i understand it yeah but i
don't agree
that they are the republican party
is against minorities and they're a part
i don't think that they're a party of
racism no matter what the media says
yeah because there are minorities in the
party and that's just my beliefs on it
but other people actually believe that
the republican party
hate minorities yeah so i mean and
that's their prerogative that's what
they believe
literally and figuratively it's not so
black and white right
it's a very very gray area in in general
that's why it's like
um i always even think about the idea of
like you can have like
a stance on civil rights social
injustice things like that but once you
go into the conversation of politics
that doesn't necessarily always play in
terms
of like an outcome of what you want to
get done in your country or your
community
you know what i'm saying so um you got
to really really pay attention to the
action the outcome the details the end
game all of that
and at the end of the day for a guy like
ice cube like he's an articulate man
obviously right he's a lyricist so to
even be able to use the
right words to speak his truth and what
he has to do
as people are like shaming him or
telling him that like you know he's a
hypocrite or whatever like
i see the strength in his like desire
and his passion to like do something
good for his own community his own
people and i can
support that before saying that he's a
hypocrite
or saying that like he's doing something
wrong you know why he didn't even have
to use his ak
because today was a good day
[Music]
you